how to get a translation job on oDesk so
I got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
YUM who wrote in to say I'm considering
to apply for English Japanese translator
job through Oh dance and do you have any
tips for that it'd be greatly
appreciated thank you this is a great
question I love oDesk if you haven't
seen oh that's catchy go check it out
it's uh Oh Oh des kay calm I've hired a
number of people throughout us including
Christina who edits and does all these
videos thank you Christina great
resource for entrepreneurs so this is
coming from the other side now this is
for someone who wants to apply to be
hired on oDesk and for a translation job
I recently just hired somebody to help
me with my presentation that when I went
to Malaysia for so hired a Malay English
translator and here's what I look for
and this is what you want to do to stand
out as a contractor and oDesk the first
is be fast okay one of the biggest fears
with hiring somebody who's not in your
office which is gonna be on oDesk or any
outsource worker is reliability so be
fast you know you may not apply the job
really quickly may not be the first one
to apply but you could be the fastest to
respond to email so there's always an
email dog that goes back and forth be
fast apply quickly right let just let
them know that you care about this and
that you are reliable that should be
that should be basic stuff but a lot of
people get that wrong and they take a
day or two days to get back by that time
I've moved on
you take two days to get back to me
about a job I'm hiring somebody else so
be fast in your responses the second is
educate so educate educate the buyer one
of the people that impressed me the most
on the malay translation job was she was
talking about all the differences in the
malay language and that people coming
from different backgrounds might be
speaking dialects and there's a you know
authentic way to speak malay and and the
writing that made her stand out more
okay so example in english you know we
have canadian english and we have
american english and it's close but it's
not the same thing and so if you're
writing for canadian audience you have
to make some modifications and if i'm
hiring somebody
you know I may not know I don't know the
difference isn't in Japanese language
but all I know is I need to get my piece
of content translated from English to
Japanese and if I want to have this
video transcribed in Japanese maybe I'd
hire someone to do it but I don't know
anything about Japanese I don't know if
there's a specific way to write dialects
whatever so educate me write it shows
that you're a professional because the
goal here is not to compete on price
because when you're when you're bidding
on something on oDesk you're gonna have
people who are coming in super low and
people were coming in much higher right
if you're coming in at $15 an hour and
somebody else is charging $3 an hour how
do you compete right how do you stand
out you have to show that you know what
you're talking about and this is a way
to educate the customer so it makes you
stand out and I feel more confidence
that you can deliver a great product for
me that you know what you're doing
compared to everybody else and the third
one is wow your buyer find a way to make
them see Wow find a way to stand out all
of these jobs a translation job when I
posted that Malay translation job I
don't know I had maybe 30 applications
you do a Japanese one you're gonna have
tons right you're going up against a lot
of people so you have to find a way to
wow your customers and it could be as
simple as saying your I went to your
website and I loved it and I believed in
the in your mission I love what you're
up to
like just show me that you did a little
bit of extra work because a lot of these
people will hire you on an ongoing basis
right I've hired people so like
Christina or Monsour or you know people
who work for me
they started off I hired them for one
project one project to see how it goes
and then I needed them more and more and
I had to increase their hours and
increase what they do for me right so
you have an opportunity to build a
long-term relationship with each of
these buyers who are coming each of
these new clients that are coming to me
it may become a full-time gig for you if
that's something that you want but to
get in the door you have to wow them
you've got to do something that's
different that shows them that you did a
little bit extra research that shows
them that you care
okay so so look at their websites see
what you can pull out if they're on
Twitter follow them talk to them on
Twitter comment on their stuff find the
way to wow them beyond just applying for
the job because that's what everybody
else is doing
okay so again make sure you're fast
respond quickly to every email that
comes in be responsive show that you
care to show your knowledge explain the
difference educate the customer and
three find a way to wow them you do that
then you can justify church and higher
prices and you're more likely to get the
job believe lucy watching liked the
video thumbs up leave a comment below
let me know you think ask the question
I'll make a video response just like
this one and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you guys
so much and I'll see you soon